- Khan Academy, welcome to
The Daily Homeroom livestream,
for those of y'all that
this is your first time.
This is, really just a way
for us to stay connected
during school closures.
Obviously, Khan Academy
we have many resources
for students, teachers and
parents to be able to work
whether the school is
in session physically,
or, whether it's happening at home,
as I think most of y'all
are now having to cope with.
And we realize, above and
beyond those resources,
in math and English and
language arts, and science
and humanities that go
from pre-K through college,
that we need to provide more support.
It's our duty as a not
for profit with a mission
to provide a free world
class education for anyone,
anywhere to step up right
now in this time of crisis.
And so that's why we're
doing teacher webinars,
parent webinars, this
daily homeroom live stream
for everyone as well as, things
like, the daily schedules
that many of y'all are now leveraging.
To think about how to structure your days,
for students of different age groups.
I will remind everyone as I always do,
that we are a not for profit organization.
And, we are supportive, the
only reason we can exist
is because of philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
And even before this crisis,
we were operating at a deficit
and now during this
crisis, our server traffic
is up two and a half,
approaching three times
our registrations from
students and parents,
are actually students and
teachers are six fold,
parent registrations are 20 fold.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about
donating to Khan Academy.
I do wanna give a special shout
out to several corporations
who stepped up in record
time when they realized
that we needed help
and not just generally,
but especially in this
COVID response period.
Bank of America stepped
up in that first weekend,
followed by AT&T,
Google.org and now Novartis,
this has been incredible help.
Any of you who are corporate leaders
or work for corporations,
we need more help.
So I would love to add logos to this.
And for all of you individuals out there,
we still are running at
a significant deficit.
So every donation matters,
whether it's as small
as the $3 donation, $5, $10.
We know that that is hard earned money
and, we really appreciate
it, but we really do need it,
if we wanna support kids around the world,
and parents and teachers.
So today we have a fairly
exciting live stream.
We have a clinical
psychologist, David Anderson.
I encourage everyone,
I say this every time
to start putting questions
on Facebook and YouTube
that you might have for
either our guest, Dave
or myself about anything,
but we're gonna talk about something
that is very front of mind
for a lot of folks right now.
We are all socially distanced.
Many of us have kids at home,
kids are trying to stay learning,
but there's many other
things that are going on
in all of our minds.
Anxiety is up, stress is up for everyone.
And I'm hoping Dave can help us navigate.
And I'm speaking not
just as a representative
of the Khan Academy community.
I'm also speaking as a
parent who has seen some of,
some of our, some of the difficulties
of what we're going through.
So thanks for joining us, Dave.
And you know, maybe the first question
is any general advice you have for parents
and students who are just trying
to cope with everything
going on right now.
- Right, well, look, thanks for having me.
It's wonderful to be able to be here
and to have a forum to kind of talk
about some of these things.
You know, we have a
practice on both coasts,
about 60 clinicians in
Child Mind Institute,
and we're hearing a lot
from parents and students.
I would say that, you
know, the first things
that are the top of mind,
especially for parents are
to manage expectations.
I mean, the biggest
thing is that none of us
have encountered challenges
like this before.
And I count myself within
that with two children.
You know, and something
we're trying to manage
the work lives that we
were, attempted managed
before this crisis hit with childcare
and without many of the
major supports that we have,
you know, a time of
online schooling is tough.
It's gonna be tough for anybody.
So, some of the first things we talked
to parents about are taking it to do lists
and that kind of level of perfectionism
they would normally expect of themselves.
And really trying to
edit those things down
as much as possible to ensure
that there's something
manageable each day.
And you have a moment to
kind of mindfully pause
and perhaps enjoy some
of the silver linings
of this in terms of time spent with family
and an opportunity to
connect a little bit more.
- And what should we keep a lookout on,
for our children or even for ourselves?
I know you focus on children especially,
but as a just a clinical
psychologist generally,
you know, I think sometimes you can,
things can happen in bits and pieces
and you know, you've gone too
far before and it's too late.
And, what should we look out for,
signs of difficulty in our
kids or even ourselves.
- I mean the reality to your point,
is we always say this
thing that child therapy
is so much about it being
mediated by the parents,
and parents aren't necessarily
the cause of the child's
particular difficulties,
but they're often the solution.
So we spent, probably
about a half the time
spending talking to
parents even when the child
might be the particular
focus of our intervention
and you know, in terms of
how parents can support kids
at the moment and what we can,
we can help them to think about,
especially with online schooling,
cause I'll go back to one
of your earlier questions.
It's that, you know,
we're, everybody's adapting
this kind of new normal
like, schools are trying
to outline assignments in certain ways
and make it so that, it's
manageable for the kids
and they may not necessarily
be getting data in real time
from parents related to
what the kids can handle
and what kind of scaffolding they need.
I think the kids we're
especially concerned
about at the moment, for
our clinical population
are those with mental health
and learning disorders
that normally are supported
in allowing them access
to a school curriculum in school,
but which, you know, we may see
a lack of those kinds of support services
or where parents are being
asked to be therapists,
speech language pathologist
and teacher all in one.
And that's something that's exceedingly
difficult for everybody right now.
- And how are you all
supporting those parents
or supporting those students?
- Yeah, a lot of it is,
retooling our clinical services
to be digital at this time.
So in many ways we're starting
from a kind of population
focused prevention level,
in that Child Mind Institute
now has two Facebook lives per day.
I did a section on the
website, which you can see here
on Coronavirus support and resources
just for supporting families and includes
links to our daily tips
and Facebook lives.
A link to phone consultations
that we can provide right now
for families that are having difficulty.
And then also articles
that are really focused
on coping with Coronavirus crisis.
We've tried to make those
articles targeted to age groups,
to parents stress management,
incorporation of mindfulness,
and then specific diagnostic clusters
where parents may be experiencing
a certain kind of unique difficulties,
say for kids on the autism spectrum
or kids who might have
difficulty with behavior.
So I thank you for scrolling
through that section
of our website right there.
You can also, I'll be
doing these Facebook lives
twice next week, so if
folks have questions
that go unanswered
between you and me, Sal,
they can catch me again
a little bit later.
- No, this is super useful.
And then we're getting a
lot of interesting questions
here for you Dave.
This first one is from YouTube.
Molly Franklin asks, as an extrovert,
how can I keep from losing
my mind during quarantine?
Exclamation mark.
- That's a really good question.
I mean, you know, I
think that in many ways
we've seen an explosion of
these kinds of self categorizing
terms on Twitter and on
the internet right now,
where folks realize like
in terms of the definition
of extrovert, we see it
operationalized right now
and on the internet as somebody
who really gets their energy
and really feels like
their mood gets a boost
in any given day, from the
contact, the close contact
in person that they
have with other people,
that's where they get their energy.
And so look, what we try to do at first
is help extroverts to, cope
in a sort of accepting way,
in that, we know that
it's not gonna be the best
in terms of how to support
their mental health right now.
We know that a lot of the ways
that they would normally draw energy
or get a mood boost are
not available to them.
So it's about thinking as
creatively as possible.
We try to assess with people,
what the level of
relationship is with anybody
they might currently be
socially distancing with,
how they can make the most
of those safe in-person connections.
And then similarly how they
can connect with others
to just do daily activities
kind of together,
in the sense that can you
watch a TV show together?
Are there online games
you can connect with
and play with other people?
And I'll give one last,
quite creative suggestion
I've seen from some of
the teenagers I treat,
which is social distancing walks,
in a sense that they'll
meet up across a block
from each other, never be on
the same side of the street,
but at least feel like
they're walking together
and can look at each
other, you know, in person.
- That's fascinating cause
I think the rational part
of our brain says, why does it matter
if we're watching that, you know
that Netflix show at the same time.
But to your point there is something
deep inside of us that says,
Oh, other people are
experiencing it at the same time.
- And that's the thing, I'm
deep into cheer right now.
Next up is Tiger King.
But I think for all of us, it's that,
you know, if we don't have a partner
or another family member to watch with,
it becomes a question of
can we watch with a friend
or, you know, do this over
some sort of online forum
where somebody is on
FaceTime at the same time
as we're watching on television
and we're watching in real time together.
It at least gives some
sense of shared experience,
particularly for extroverts
really feed off that.
We even see people
- And that's some of the logic
- Cook the same food together.
Sorry, yeah.
- Oh, that's cool.
Cook the same food and then share a meal
that's a neat idea.
- Exactly, and you get
to compare, you know,
who did it best and you know,
kind of tinker with each other's recipes.
There's a lot that can happen with that,
especially if your friend is
a better chef than you are.
- (laughs) Yeah.
Although, you could
pretend that your own dish
was the more delicious,
no one will ever know.
But, this is somewhat
the logic you can always,
Obviously we could do video
versions of this live stream.
And then it might even, you know,
we wouldn't have our
little technical glitches
that sometimes we have
with our, our broadband.
- Sorry (speaking off mic)
- No one should feel
broadband guilt at this point.
(laughs)
But, this is the value, that
we're all globally right now
having this shared experience.
And we're getting a ton of
more questions from Facebook.
Taylor Cobian asks, how do
you cope with school work load
without getting distracted?
Personally, as a high school student,
I'm struggling with staying focused
since I have ADHD, advice.
- So my first job at
the Child Mind Institute
was running our clinical
center for kids with ADHD
and behavioral issues.
So this is, this is right
in my clinical wheelhouse.
So thank you for the softball.
I mean, look, with a lot of the patients
that we're working with
with ADHD right now,
you know, we know certain things,
we know that if they get
sleep, focus can be better.
If they take medicine,
it's important to think about the timing
and when they're gonna get
the most benefit from that.
And then beyond that,
it's important to think
about organizational skills
and the structuring of the day.
So with a lot of my patients right now,
we'll think about,
especially with adolescents,
even though they may be
waking up slightly earlier
than they were say, during the school day,
we're structuring their workspace,
to make sure it's as free
of distractions as we can.
Maybe putting any distracting devices
where friends might be
trying to contact us
outside the door or
elsewhere in the house.
We're trying to get good
work blocks in the day.
So trying to make sure we've
got at least one work block
before lunch and perhaps starting
with some of the more ambitious tasks,
that we know will have less
energy to really tackle
or focus, to really
tackle later in the day.
Structuring good meals and breaks
and really trying to not save
a lot of the challenging work.
More like the easy stuff
you can kind of knock off,
for the late nighttime
either when medicine
or motivation has really worn off
and it's about kind of, you know,
managing yourself like that.
And then if you can't
talk back to yourself
to combat procrastination effectively,
sometimes we've seen teens
and college students,
really try to get accountability buddies,
who can kind of keep them on task and say,
all right, let me meet
with you for five minutes
at the beginning of the day.
What's your list?
And then, you know, how can
we make sure we check in,
in a non-judgmental way
to keep you on track.
- That's super powerful.
A lot of what you described, once again,
the rational parts of our brains, like,
Oh, why should I have
to text message a friend
when I've checked something off
of my, off of my to do list?
Or why should I have to eat
a, you know, watch a movie.
But there's, at the same
time there's someone else.
But there's something
very powerful about having
that community accountability
to what you're doing.
And we've talked about it
at previous live streams,
just, just getting started,
having those early wins,
but do some of the high
cognitive little things
early with breaks,
that's super good advice.
- And it's really also,
that friends can help us
be accountable in a
more non-judgmental way.
Not to mention friends are often the ones
who are the most gentle with us
and helping us to be self-compassionate
and also to realize we deserve breaks.
Even if we weren't as efficient
in a given day as we expected we would be.
- You have better friends than I do.
Mine are quite, no, I'm kidding.
(laughter)
- You choose the accountability
buddies carefully.
- Yes, you should see some
of the texts accountability
that I have with my friends
when we have one group,
where we text each other
whenever we eat something
we should not and, they are
not, they're quite harsh.
We are all harsh to each other.
- I've seen folks do
things where their friend
will control a certain
portion of their money
and it will be donated to
a cause they don't support,
if they you know, don't
accomplish their goals,
for to a cause they could do support.
If it does, you know you can
set up lots of different,
you know, schemes for
yourself with your friends.
- That's powerful.
So, this next question is from YouTube.
And actually this is
something where we could
probably both take a stab at answering it.
YouTube, Asher Tosh Tuwary, says, hi Sal,
I wanna know how you people
are coping with COVID-19.
I wanna know how y'all are
keeping your offices running
and I'll take a stab at it.
And I'd love Dave, you know,
you're also in an organization,
I'd love to think about how
you personally are coping
and your organization, but, Asher Tosh,
you know, Khan Academy,
it's, this is a tarred time
for everyone, obviously.
Some of the good things that
Khan Academy had going forward
is we already had about
35% of our workforce,
was what we would say
remote or distributed.
And so, we had a lot of
the infrastructure in place
where we could do meetings
over Google Hangouts or zoom.
We would use things like
Google docs to be able
to collaborate and so, that aspect of it
has been relatively okay for Khan Academy,
although it's still been difficult.
I think the part that's been much harder
is now a lot of our team
members are at home,
their children, many of them
have very young children are at home.
And you can imagine getting work done,
while you're also doing childcare,
especially if your
children are very young.
It's very difficult.
And I know many of the
parents and teachers
out there listening are
coping with the same thing.
You know, I consider
myself very fortunate.
We have you know, I have
three young children,
my wife and my mother-in-law lives with us
and that helps us kind of, be
able to tag team a little bit.
And especially, since the
COVID crisis has been going on
and Khan Academy's load,
and in fact my workload
has gotten even higher than
it typically would have been.
Even pre-crisis.
You know, I really have to thank my wife
and my mother-in-law for stepping up,
and, and filling in the gap.
And, my wife is a
physician, a rheumatologist.
So you can imagine,
there's a lot of complexity
in her world as well.
So she's been kind of the
hero of the household lately,
but it's tough on everyone.
And I think we all just have to, you know,
take one step at a time
and to quote Frozen II,
do the next right thing.
Dave, I'd love to hear personally,
how, how are you coping and
your family and your work?
- I just thought my son's
favorite character is Elsa.
So if I can mix flexibility,
gratitude and frozen references
into my speech here,
you know, I think that,
that was pretty perfect.
Now, you know, I think
that it at Child Mind,
you know, we have, 300 employees
across a couple of coasts
and similar to you, there
were aspects of our work,
that were, as a nonprofit
that were already online
and, you know, fruitful for collaboration
even when we're working at distance.
I think others like clinical
care, have both suffered
and then also been adapted
in new and inventive ways
to serve our patients in
the sense that we all knew
that the models of treatment
that we use for children,
adolescents and families,
are most tested in person,
but, in an environment like this,
in many ways, we've seen
organizations like ourselves,
kind of figure out how
we can become borderless,
in that we can serve with
consultations or clinical care
and really creative ways
using video camera coaching
with parents at home or all
kinds of different formats
online just to get in
touch with our patients
and to really make sure
we can provide support
as best we can during this time.
Like you, I have a three year
old and a seven month old
at home and the only way that
I've been able to function
or keep work up is because
of my wonderful wife
and in-laws who also live with us.
But even with that said, my son is used to
a bounded lifestyle, my
son, my three-year-old
and where daddy goes to
work each day in an office
and he goes to his pre-school.
And the fact that I'm working upstairs
has been a real adjustment period for him,
in the sense that he
doesn't really understand
why he can't be involved in everything.
And so I've tried to work out a rhythm,
where I take a long lunch break
within each day outside in the yard.
We need, you know, have at least a meeting
with a team member of mine, not a patient
that he joins each day.
And then I just try to drop everything,
the second the workday is over,
and spend a good bit of time with him.
But I think everybody's trying to find
their balance that way.
- You know, whenever I start
to feel sorry for ourselves
because of my youngest is five years old
and he's a little bit difficult sometimes,
I remind myself of those of
you who have a three year old
or a seven month old at home.
So, my sympathies, that's hard.
- The funniest thing is that, you know,
in the midst of this,
I think my wife and I,
had so many goals for, you know,
where we'd like him to be right now.
Like, you know, we've gotten
through potty training
the last year, like he's
sleeping in his own, big kid bed,
and, just in the last few
nights, in the last week or so,
he's found it unable to
sleep through the night
without one of us in his bed.
And we're just adapting to that.
Like, I think in the
normal rhythm of life,
we'd say to ourselves,
no, we've got to set some boundaries here.
But the reality is our kids,
we're trying to stay healthy.
We're trying to keep everybody
safe and their mood up.
So, you know, what's a little
bit of relaxing of boundaries
right now if it makes
everybody feel safe and loved.
- Well, that's actually a good segue
to this next question that I have here.
And this is, you know,
the screen time question
has always been a question,
but obviously a lot of us
are relying on screen time,
both socially and
academically and work-wise.
So from Facebook, Samson
Senate Senateda or Sign Thado,
I thought it was a really
assigned data trick,
tricking the metric username, I like that.
Well, Sam sign sign data, is
it good for kids to go online
for three hours in the
morning even with breaks?
Some kids complain of
headaches and bleary eyes.
Yeah, I'd love your, you know,
there's the pre-COVID screen time debate
and now there's the current
COVID screen time debate.
- I just did a webinar for
parents on this last week,
where we talked about how pre-COVID,
the checklist was, you know,
in terms of stressing out
over screen time balance,
we ask parents, let's check off
a number of developmental boxes.
And as long as you've got those things,
you may not have to worry
about how much free time
your child is spending on screens.
As long as you're kind
of monitoring content
and the interactions.
And we would check off, you know,
are they invested in school,
do they have extracurricular activities?
Do you have some family time,
you know, do they have face
to face contact with friends
and are they getting enough sleep?
Those would be some of the
things on the checklist.
The way it's switched for COVID
is around basic wellness practices
and then the fact that the
balance has really shifted,
in that we're asking parents,
okay, is everybody in the house eating?
Do you know where your
food is coming from?
Let's check like kind of
hierarchy of needs type things.
You know, do you feel like
everyone's getting enough sleep?
How can we help with that?
Are people getting exercise in some form?
Are you finding ways
to give yourself breaks
above and beyond school
or work responsibilities?
And you know, it's, it's this question
of once you've kind of
checked off those boxes
of finding just ways to
engage in basic routines
of wellness over the course of the day.
We're trying to get people to
really think about relaxing,
that, you know, if you
wanna focus on say an hour
or two a day to find
screen free activities,
destruction for kids,
congratulate yourself
and then you know, monitor the content
and monitor what they're
watching of course.
But it's okay to relax the
boundaries during this time
and we'll snap them back over the summer
when everybody can be maybe outside
and hopefully when we're
through this to some degree.
- Right, it's an interesting struggle
cause we're always, you
know, we always feel guilty
to some degree, I mean
there's good screen time
and not so good screen time
or neutral screen time,
but obviously we're
all leaning on it more.
But it's your point, all
of our own mental health,
we all need actually might,
might need some screen time
to connect with folks, to learn.
But it also, if it, if it
can help offload a parent
for even half an hour, an
hour and give them a break,
if their stress level goes
down, it helps the student.
- And this goes back, to the
American Academy of Pediatrics
recommendations regarding screen time,
where, you know, they're conservative
but at the same time they
really focus on the idea
that mediated viewing with a child,
in a sense that you watch
something with the kid
and talk about it or educational
high quality programming.
This is gonna sound like a plant,
but many of my patients and families
are watching Khan Academy,
you know, as part of this
because you know, in that
sense there are parents
that have said, look, if my
kids are gonna be on screens
and that's gonna be how
they're gonna occupy themselves
through this crisis, I may as
well make some good choices
about what I'm exposing them to.
And there'll be some time that I give them
where they choose it.
And then other times where I say,
here's a forum that I know
is all high quality content,
choose from this and occupy
thyself with something,
you know, like the boxer
rebellion I saw framed,
you know, on your white or
your chalkboard behind you,
that's a great thing
- That has been in my to do for a while.
I still have not made the boxer rebellion.
I'm well-researched on it,
but, I haven't made it yet.
But,
- In that case, we're previewing
that it's coming contents
that people
- It's been up there for a while.
I gotta be careful what I write up there.
So, the next, next
question was maybe almost,
almost asymmetric opposite of that.
Well, maybe it's related from Facebook,
Surabi Srivastava says,
how to manage a teenager
who's taking the quarantine
like fish to water,
need to break him away from the screen
with very limited choices.
So this is a parent who's
worried because it's maybe
their child really likes this COVID world.
- It is, we're, we're hearing that,
I'm sorry, my reception is jumping again,
but we're, we're hearing that
a lot from teenage parents
is that we get one of two
concerns in one of two directions.
It's either I'm worried
about how my teenager's
gonna cope with the lack of, you know,
connection with friends.
How do I deal with that?
And that kind of references the answer
I gave to an earlier question.
And then there's the, they're
not coming out of their room
like, you know, do you, do
you think they're depressed
or could it be that
they're just, you know,
not liking time spent with their family
or they're liking this too much
and all our possible conclusions,
you know, we've helped many a parent
to just kind of think through the fact
that your teenager
isn't, is in their room,
may not necessarily mean their mood is low
or they've experienced any
disruption in their eating
or sleeping patterns or you know,
that they're feeling all hopeless.
They may just be enjoying
themselves like a pig in mud,
in that sense.
So you know, when, when
we see this kind of thing
with teenagers, we've
tried to talk parents
through two kind of major strategies.
One is just kind of trying to
get to their non-negotiables.
You know, when do you want your
teenager out of their room,
family meals, at least an hour a day.
Maybe they gotta take a walk outside
cause you have decreed they
have to get some exercise,
while practicing social distancing.
You know, we get those non negotiables.
And then the other thing,
we've been coaching parents on
is strategies to keep the
teenager out of their room
when they spontaneously emerge.
So in that sense, we try
to coach teenage parents
or parents of teenagers on, you know,
trying not to pepper
the kiddo with questions
the moment they walk out,
use declarative statements,
praise something you
know, they might've done.
Like, it really seemed
like you were working
on your English essay hard earlier today,
or hey, you know, I'm
making spaghetti sauce,
you always know how to make it just right.
You know, it's that you're trying to draw
them out with skills they have,
value to the family, you
know, and conversation,
rather than, did you get
your schoolwork done today?
You know, what else was on your list,
which inevitably sends a
teenager back into their room.
- Yeah, I really liked that last point.
You know, a lot of times I always say,
and this isn't based on research,
but more just gut senses.
You know, teenagers,
especially our prodo adults,
you know, biologically the
nature would allow them
to be even be parents, not recommending it
by any stretch of the imagination,
but that implies that
they are psychologically
and biologically capable
of caring for themselves
and others.
But modern society has
kind of just kept them
only worrying about themselves.
And your last point about
helping with the pasta,
it's really like, hey, let's make,
I'm gonna treat you like an adult
or a pro prodo adult or pre adult.
I'm gonna give you some responsibility
for the household as well.
- I think what you're highlighting
is the intersection of
resources, socio-economic status,
cultural background and maturity
in the sense that, you know,
in within kind of American culture,
we have sort of a period
of extended adolescence
in which we've really very gradually
ask teenagers who are seeking novelty,
or seeking new experiences,
to take on responsibilities.
Now that is very much converging
with the fact that if
parents are experiencing
job insecurity during this
time or they're overwhelmed
for childcare, we're
often asking teenagers
to take on a larger share
of their responsibility
In a crisis like this one or when someone
is confronting that kind of, you know,
situation just in general.
So it really, you know,
the question of a teenager
takes to COVID a little bit
too much, usually entails
the fact that that teenager's
main responsibility
prior to this was perhaps school.
And you know, that in some sense it's okay
if we're a little bit
stricter about the idea
that we need some help during this time.
And it may be, it may behoove them
to kind of serve the
family a little bit better
than they might have
otherwise since their day job,
school has sort of shifted this.
- Yeah, and I think we have time
for maybe one more question.
There's a couple of questions
that are in this category.
This is, from several folks
who are talking about feeling stressed,
either when they're trying
to learn a specific thing
like math or reading or feeling stressed
because they actually have
a fairly large to do list
from school and they're feeling
like they're not able to do it.
What tips do you have to those students
who are feeling stressed?
- Yeah, I mean, part of it is that I think
everybody's managing this crisis together.
So more so than ever, it both feels alone,
but you're not alone.
So, you know, the reality is we're hearing
from so many students who will tell us
I can't manage the workload
or I feel so ashamed
because the other
students seem to be taking
to this online learning
like a fish out of water,
but not me.
And I don't, we don't really meet people
who are finding it easy during this time.
So I think it's more that
we wanna encourage people
to reach out to their fellow students
for how they're coping with this
and to reach out to their teachers
because we're all, I think, you know,
functioning on more limited time
and, kind of head space
than we normally have.
But at the same time, we wanna help.
Like we know that a switch from in-person
to online schooling will
not come without bumps.
And so for that reason we've seen teachers
more so than ever, you know, interested
in connecting really quick individually
to try to help a student
through something.
We're figuring out how
they can get support.
And I think that a lot of teenagers we see
and college students are
really surprised by that.
- Yeah, and I'll just add to that,
because we've been seeing
that type of stress,
not just among students
using Khan Academy,
but we've been seeing it
even in our own employee base
where you know, folks have, you know,
their head space has shrunk.
There's a baseline of
anxiety or dread going on
and then they're taking care of kids.
They have a, might have a,
a family member who's having
financial difficulty cause they lost.
I mean there's just all sorts
of stresses that are going on.
And then they're also
trying to do their work
and they're feeling
almost guilt or stress.
They're like, Oh my God, the goals
that I thought I was gonna be able to do
are not realistic anymore.
And what we're telling our team members,
and what we tell everyone
is no one is judging anyone right now.
Anyway, I only judge the
people who are judging others,
right now (laughs)
- We keep telling folks,
you take bite sized chunks
and then you do it in this
as high quality as you can,
but don't think about quantity
or the same productivity
right now, no one's capable of
- Right, and no one is judging it,
and you just have to release yourself.
I think, for example, a lot of schools,
even my own children's school,
they've given a very robust list of things
for the students to do.
But, I think I can speak on their behalf.
They completely get that
if kids or their parents
are not in a position to keep the kids
to do everything on that checklist,
it's completely okay.
We're all trying to
cope with this situation
in whatever way we can.
So, Dave, thanks so much for joining.
We're at time every day.
This, you know, this
half an hour goes by fast
and today was even faster than normal.
A sign of how much fun we're having.
I think you're gonna be able to join us
hopefully in future live streams.
And I just wanna tell everyone
as what Dave and I just said,
you know, you might feel
physically separated from others
and Dave gave some good
ideas for how you might
feel a little bit mentally closer,
or emotionally closer to
others in this time of crisis.
And the whole point of this live stream
is for all of us to realize
that we're in this together.
The whole world is going through this.
So as best as you can, you
know, keep safe and stay healthy
and don't beat up yourself too much,
and take some time to breathe, relax,
meditate, whatever it
takes to kind of give
yourself that mental reset.
We'll see you tomorrow.
- Brilliant advice.